Людство знайомиться з 15-ю літерою грецького алфавіту - омікрон.
Новий варіант коронавірусу набагато заразніший, ніж досі відомі варіації.
Вірусологи б’ють на сполох. Вже відбувся екстрений саміт
міністрів охорони здоров'я країн-членів "великої сімки".
Отже, що наразі відомо про омікрон?
Новий варіант B.1.1.529 вперше був зареєстрований
11 листопада у Ботсвані, тобто на північ
від Південно-Африканської Республіки.
Але найбільше випадків виявили саме в ПАР.
Особливо навколо Йоганнесбурга та Преторії.
Відтоді повідомлення про нові випадки зараження
омікроном почали з'являтися у всьому світі:
в Канаді, Азії, Австралії та Європі.
Зокрема, декілька випадків зараження омікроном
підтвердилися і в Німеччині. Країна і так нині переживає
найважчу фазу пандемії: лікарні в деяких регіонах
переповнені настільки, що солдати Бундесверу допомагають
переправляти пацієнтів з ковідом до інших міст.
Омікрон має надзвичайно велику кількість мутацій,
а саме 32. Для порівняння: досі найзаразніший варіант
дельта мав 8 мутацій.
Через таку велику кількість мутацій з новим варіантом вірусу
важче боротися імунним клітинам, адже він уникає
імунної відповіді - це так звана "імунна втеча".
Вірусологи припускають, що велика кількість мутацій
у варіанті омікрон, швидше за все, сформувалася в організмі
пацієнта, який страждає на хронічну інфекційну хворобу
і має ослаблену імунну систему.
При цьому новий варіант не означає перебіг хвороби з якимись
особливими ускладненнями. Його небезпека насамперед у тому,
що цей вірус поширюватиметься швидше і це відповідно
може швидше перевантажити систему охорони здоров’я.
Крім того, внаслідок вже згадуваної "імунної втечі"
вакцинація стає менш ефективною. За словами вірусологів,
порівняно з варіантами альфа і дельта омікрон буде
гірше розпізнаватись антитілами, які мали б нейтралізувати його.
Водночас ґрунтовних епідеміологічних даних про те,
наскільки заразний новий варіант коронавірусу поки що немає.
Всесвітня організація охорони здоров'я уважно вивчає
ситуацію з новим варіантом коронавірусу
і рекомендує активізувати зусилля з тестування та секвенування.
ВООЗ також закликає країни повідомляти у разі появи
на їхній території цього варіанту. Омікрону вже присвоїли
статус такого, "що викликає занепокоєння".
Сама поява омікрону є ще одним нагадуванням про те, що
- хоча багато хто з нас, можливо, і думав, що з ковідом покінчено -
небезпека нікуди не зникла.
У ВООЗ також наполягають на тому, щоб максимально
пришвидшити вакцинацію від COVID-19, особливо серед груп ризику
або тих, що залишаються невакцинованими.
У Єврокомісії теж наполегливо закликають
населення вакцинуватися.
Найвищим пріоритетом є вакцинація, вакцинація та ревакцинація -
наскільки це тільки можливо.
Тому що посилення вакцинації підвищує рівень антитіл
та стимулює клітини для боротьби з коронавірусом.
У Нідерландах із 600 пасажирів, які напередодні прибули
на двох рейсах з ПАР, у 61 виявили коронавірус,
причому 13 з них заражені омікроном.
Усіх хворих відправили на карантин до готелю поряд з аеропортом.
У Нідерландах запроваджено комендантську годину:
о 17 годині закриваються практично всі магазини, бари
та інші заклади, крім продуктових магазинів та аптек.
Щоб уповільнити поширення нового варіанту, інші країни
теж вдаються до вже відомих заходів: від комендантської години
та обмеження поїздок до тестування і відстеження контактів.
Деякі держави вчинили ще радикальніше і вже
призупинили авіасполучення з країнами півдня Африки.
Ізраїль та Японія першими закрили свої кордони
для іноземних громадян. Влада ПАР вважає такі обмеження надмірними.
Ми закликаємо країни, які запровадили заборону
на поїздки до нашої країни та інших братніх
південноафриканських країн, якнайшвидше
скасувати свої рішення і зняти введену ними заборону,
перш ніж буде завдано ще більшої шкоди нашій економіці
та джерелам доходу нашого населення.
У пацієнтів, заражених новим варіантом коронавірусу,
поки що не спостерігалося якихось ускладнень під час хвороби.
Найчастіше хворі скаржаться на ломоту в тілі
та надмірну втому. Втім, лікарі не виключають,
що м'який перебіг хвороби пов'язаний з тим, що
досі омікроном заражалися переважно молоді люди.
Експерти наголошують, що новий варіант вірусу поки що
занадто мало вивчений, щоб робити висновки про те,
наскільки він небезпечний.
Тим часом, виробники вакцин заявили, що готові
створити бустерне щеплення, адаптоване до омікрону.
Проте спершу необхідно дочекатися більш надійних результатів
досліджень нового варіанту коронавірусу.